mr depp's world you don't leave mr death
and if you do
he will start a campaign of global
humiliation against you
a smear campaign that lasts to this very
day
he will do everything he can to destroy
your life
to destroy your career
that is what they're saying ladies and
gentlemen
and that's what they're trying to get
you the jury to be an accomplice to
but it's not surprising
because mr death
cannot and will not take responsibility
for his own actions
it's always someone else's fault does
the first amendment give miss heard the
right to write the words that she wrote
in this article
on december 18 2018
that's the question
and you cannot simultaneously protect
and uphold the first amendment and find
in favor of johnny depp on his claim you
simply cannot you have to decide should
someone be able to write an article like
that in the united states of america
without being sued successfully without
having to go through the hell that miss
hurt has gone through think about every
piece of evidence that you've heard over
the last six weeks about his abuse about
their relationship
none of that is in the article
none of it
we all know that it would be a very
different article if she had written
about what she suffered that she's told
you about over the last six weeks
because he knows the words are true mr
depp says that the words now have a
defamatory implication he says the
statements are the same as saying
johnny depp abused me
but just because he wants to make the
article about himself doesn't mean it is
he has to show you
that any defamatory implication was
designed and intended
look at number four designed and
intended by ms misheard to convey the
defamatory meaning that he suggests just
because people might read the article
and remember oh yeah amber heard used to
be married to johnny depp
and she accused him of abuse that
doesn't mean that she designed and
intended defamatory implications in
writing about herself and think about it
if mr depp is right then virtually any
statement that anyone could ever make
about their own life that implies
anything implies any involvement with
any other person could be defamatory and
that's clearly not what the first
amendment
intends
she didn't design and intend the words
to be the equivalent of writing johnny
depp abused me and you don't have to
take her words for it you can take the
words of terence doherty of the aclu he
said that the op-ed wasn't even
misheard's idea
the aclu wrote the first draft and great
care was taking taken in drafting the
article so as not to make it about mr
death or miss herd's relationship with
him
that's the only evidence presented about
miss hurt's motive except her admit her
her statements that that was exactly
what she wanted to do she wanted to talk
about her experiences after johnny depp
ms heard didn't write the headline
she didn't approve the headline
she had nothing to do with it she was
not given notice of the headline she
testified you saw her testify about the
sexual assault that she experienced at
the hands of mr death you saw her
testify about that that they're calling
her a liar
you saw her on the stand testify with
your own mouth
with her own mouth
exactly
exactly what she went through
for the first time in court because
people
who have suffered that they don't want
to broadcast that to the world
they want to penalize miss hurd for not
speaking about that earlier that's
ridiculous and it's insulting and it's
just victim blaming at its most
disgusting
the only reference to sexual assault in
the article
and you can read the op-ed
is sexual assault that she said she had
experienced by the time she was of
college age before mr depp so there is a
reference to sexual violence in that
article but it's not by mr deb
mr depp can't hold her liable for a
headline she didn't write it contained
something that had nothing that was not
about him and they want you to think
that she republished the headline
republished the headline by tweeting out
the link to the online version so let's
look at this
this is the tweet that she sent on
december 19th
the hyperlink
says opinion amber heard i spoke up
against sexual violence that's the
online version of the article as ms
heard said you can't attach you can't
tweet a piece of paper
so when she wanted to
share that she had written this article
what choice does she have
she has to attach that link
and the jury instructions that you have
make clear that
a hyperlink
is not republication
forwarding a link on does not mean that
you broadcast the statement again but
that's what they want to make you think
the only way
and the jury instructions that you have
and we won't we don't need to read
through them in detail now but the
republication instruction says that
merely linking to an article does not
amount to republication but adding
content to a linked article may
constitute republication you must
determine whether any added content was
intended to reach a new audience and if
you find any content added to the
hyperlink was intended to reach a new
audience it constitutes a republication
there was no content added to the
article let me be very clear
if amber was abused by mr depp even one
time
then she wins
one time
and we're not just talking about
physical abuse
we're talking about emotional abuse
psychological abuse
financial abuse
sexual abuse
that's what we're talking about
let's look at the evidence you heard mr
depp define abuse from his own mouth he
admitted all of that when he talked
about his childhood they're trying to
trick you into thinking that amber has
to be perfect in order to win
even while they're ignoring jade mr
depp's many flaws but don't fall for
that trick amber's not perfect none of
us are she's never pretended to be and
that's not what you're being asked to
decide
one time ladies and gentlemen one time
if he abused her one time amber wins
actually if he fails to prove that he
never abused her one time amber wins
so let's take a look at some of the
evidence this was one of the first
messages shown to mr depp
in his cross-examination
this is a message to paul bettany his
drug buddy early on in their
relationship
when he says let's burn amber let's
drown her before we burn her
i will [ __ ] her burnt corpse afterwards
to make sure she is dead
some of the most vile disgusting
language that you could ever imagine
that is what he said to her at the
beginning of the relationship
so let's look at how the relationship
was bookended
you remembered mr depp the other day in
response to some texts that we'll see
later saying i don't write like that
this is a book end of the relationship
this is after it was over
i asked mr depp to read that top text
you'll remember that was the only thing
i asked him to read and he immediately
said i didn't write that text even
though
of course he did
even though he wrote the text under word
under it that said hopefully that
rotting corpse is decomposing in the
trunk of a honda civic that's how we
bookended their relationship
ladies and gentlemen these words
are a window into the heart and mind of
america's favorite pirate
this is the real johnny depp you can't
restore his reputation you can't give
him anything they didn't tell you that
but the court told you that and that's a
very very important thing here he told
his story he had his opportunities he
had his full opportunities to do all of
that and he came in here and lied to you
and said he's here to get his reputation
back it's just one of many lies in this
case but it's a really big one because
here we are
six weeks of your time precious time six
weeks of this court's time
for what for nothing
only to go after amber
that's psychological abuse
he's going after amber for nothing
because he wants to put her through this
again
the third time
so we're fighting back and that's the
counter plane
she finally has said enough
enough
and we're asking you to finally
hold this man responsible he has never
accepted responsibility for anything in
his life once again the next day
johnny apologizes to amber
he says in two different text messages
that 772 772-773
he says my profound apologies in one of
them and my apologies are eternal in the
other one what is he apologizing for the
next day on may 22nd
if he didn't know that he did all of
those things she wasn't wearing any
makeup she was natural she wasn't
wearing a stitch of makeup every one of
them says it's the exact same thing why
would you say that she's an actor she's
not going to go outside her house you
know without putting makeup on and if
she has bruises why on earth when she's
been covering them up for four years why
on earth would she not put makeup on so
that she would cover those up
why on earth would she not want to cover
up those bruises it makes no sense but
you know what you guys saw her here you
guys saw it um
you saw amber on the stand there were
days where she didn't wear eye makeup
a lot of people
think that she's not wearing makeup when
she doesn't have mascara
and eyeliner on she has different looks
and some of them are with eye makeup and
some of them are without and people
misunderstand especially people that
aren't that good at makeup and a lot of
men frankly um go oh that's then she
probably doesn't have makeup and that's
where that mistake happens but you heard
her testimony and you heard her makeup
artist testimony saying she doesn't go
out of her room without concealer and
foundation she knows how to put these
things in and you saw defendants exhibit
155 and you'll have the actual thing in
there that's the type of palette she
used and she was very adept at telling
you what color she puts on for the
different days of bruises this is a
woman who for four years did everything
she could to cover up anybody knowing
anything about this abuse do you
honestly think she's just going to walk
around for the week with her bruises
exposed of course she's not if you do
the math amber is entitled at least 31.5
what does she take 7 million what does
she do with the 7 million she gives it
to charity or she intends to give it to
charity now they make much ado about the
pledge versus donation but both the
corporate designees for aclu and for
children's hospital said donation and
pledge are interchangeable you know
these are pledges the aclu corporate
designee said you typically do pledges
because of the tax benefits and that's
what she said she pledged it over a
period of time because of the tax
implications to it and because she was
getting paid over the time now she
started to make these donations and
you'll see that the first one was on
behalf of mr depp's uh business manager
mr white actually sent the letters with
the hundred thousand for each of those
that was the initial ones um he was
trying to take credit for those and in
fact both the aclu and children's
hospital got confused and gave the
credit to mr depp not to amber for those
then she made payments to both and elon
musk also made payments to both for 500
000 each which she didn't count to her
pledge but they help those organizations
at the end of the day she's made a
million dollars in pledge in payments to
them but then she got sued here and
hasn't been able to because she spent
six million dollars in attorney's fees
that is unrefuted she still intends to
pay those pledges honor those pledges
and she said that throughout and i
elicited from both the aclu and from
children's hospital they haven't expired
she can pay them whenever she wants to
and she fully intends to but she has to
get out from under this first they
started to get amber fired from aquaman
too they have continued to this day they
have followed her everywhere everybody
has stopped wanting her l'oreal won't
use her even though they've kept her on
from that time she lost three different
opportunities that were being discussed
with her the most significant part of
that though is that aquaman was the
biggest blockbuster ever for dc films it
was the biggest it was over a billion
dollars this was her opportunity for her
star even the experts from mr depp
admitted this was her blockbuster this
was her mega but what happened instead
as she's going through as it's coming
out and in that 16 months they were
going well nothing happened yeah lots
happened she was had three different
films she was discussing she had she got
the l'oreal contract she she got the
stand all of those things were happening
because of aquaman and then everything
shut down she wasn't allowed to do
publicity for the stand she wasn't
allowed to uh she you know hasn't been
allowed to do anything for l'oreal she
got shut down from her charitable
organizations she she ended up not
getting the amazon movie and then they
gave her a hard time about aquaman two
and instead of the career trajectory of
the other comparators who all went way
up and by the way all the experts admit
that that career trajectory went well
for all the rest of them and she's the
only one that didn't have it and the
reason is because of the defamatory
statements